okay thank you
uh as chair of the house children and
family law committee i find that due to
the state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of cover 19
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporariously
to this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic needs
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting all members of the
committee and select staff have the
ability to communicate to
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following web
address
um https colon to backslash
zoom dot us backslash small j
backslash nine nine one one six three
six five three nine three three five or
dialing one of the following phone
numbers
one three one two six two six six seven
nine nine
or one nine two nine two zero five six
zero nine nine b providing public notice
of the necessary information for
assessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
assessing accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom
or telephonically this information is
printed in a house calendar
uh c providing a mechanism for the
public to alert
the public body during a meeting if
there are problems with access
if anybody has a problem please call two
seven one
three six zero zero or email at
hcs leg dot state dot new hampshire dot
u s
d adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting to assist us
uh chris christina dyer
is the meeting host additional staff
providing support jennifer four
and bradley greenland this is a public
meeting of the house children and family
law committee
copyrighted agenda in minutes have been
posted on the main page of the general
court website
under the heading remote meetings please
note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room
with you with with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to no
law and representative connors
if you take the attendance thank you
representative mulligan a present
and i am in the school cafeteria and
uh people sometimes do walk through but
right now i am alone representative
connors is here i'm in my
office alone representative corson
representative french
representative grossman
i'm here hi everyone and i've got one
homeschooler representative levesque
i'm here i'm in the spare room alone
representative petrino i'm here
and i'm in my home office alone
representative st
john i'm here and i'm in my home office
[Music]
representative de simone can you try
again yes good morning
i'm here my husband is in the house and
may
representative rice i'm here
with riley and my husband is around
somewhere
representative horn representative
camarota
good morning i'm here in my home office
my husband
is out in the yard tinkering and a new
puppy so we'll see how that goes
representative juris representative
yokela
i'm uh here uh in concord outside so
i'm with whoever walks by representative
rooney
good morning i'm here i'm at home um and
i do have my
my daughter's at home remote learning
today
and chairman long i'm here alone
all right we have a quorum very good
thank you
uh so i'll uh we'll begin with uh
hospital 362. this is a work session and
uh has everybody gotten representative
barrions
i have read both of the communications
representative barry and you want to
if everyone's had a chance to to read it
it
basically provides
in terms of a
related to um
why this was important
um for one thing there is a requirement
child support reviewed
every four years and
um that and that was accomplished
by the carson school
unfortunately that information
came to us somewhat late
um in the process resulting
several delays
along the way um
we also had heard from
uh people who
testified uh that there was a need
to have the uh
the guidelines um updated in a number of
ways
also was that a variant your audio is
coming in hardcore
uh
uh supreme court decisions
which made it impossible for
um for the uh for there to be
any sort of adjustment for
equal or
uh shared shared
time uh among the parents
so all of this uh suggests that
yes there is a need for uh
this type of legislation in the
future um taking into account
all of the issues that are brought up
both in the supreme court decisions
yes okay
is transmitting better now
not really uh i is there any other
discussion on 360. i'm not hearing any
of you
okay so i can have our tech guy give him
a call
if you'd like um
anyone yeah can you hear me skip
make a difference if we turn along do
you
hear me yeah i hear you but you can't
hear me
representative marion you can't hear me
can you
yeah yeah i have a detective i'm gonna
call you guys
give him a call you hear me
i i can't hear you but you can't hear me
so is there any further discussing
representative de simone
i thank you chairman long um
well from what i see the shared
residential responsibility
can someone text him and ask him to go
out and come back in
that might help yes we do have um
bradley giving him a call he is actually
he's muted and the delay is actually
coming in multiple i can hear you
minutes passed chairman
okay um
okay
okay representative desimone thank you
again
chairman long and it's nice to see
everybody i miss all of you
from the way i see it um the residential
um shared responsibilities
is growing um i think that this
legislation
is necessary does it need to be fixed
perhaps so however i think that this
legislation
is
an excellent starting point i think that
if we refer it to uh or recommend
it for future legislation it's the way
to go
i think that it will help a lot of
families who are in
great distress right now um like many of
you i've received a lot of
communication from the public
they need this i have not received one
maybe some of you have and i'd like to
hear about it
i have not received one
communication that said please don't
pass this bill
every one of the communications has been
please pass this bill we needed
desperately so i think to refer it for
future
legislation is the way to go and i thank
representative long you are currently
here there you are
is there any further discussion on house
bill 362
i do see representative wazir's hand is
here if you could recognize her and have
her
senator yes and then she can say where
she
is uh for the right to know law and then
move forward
yeah we yeah we realize you're present
and we need to know if you're alone and
then
just to get you on a record yes
thank you chairman long i am president
yeah set up bluetooth i can hear you
guys
okay did you have any discussion on
hospital 362
uh no i do not okay any anybody else
representative mulligan uh
thank you chair um
i i didn't hear anything that skip
varian actually
was saying is there any way we can i
don't have his email
so is there any way that i can get that
information
i can certainly send out the uh the
drafts
yeah i've got is there anybody else that
needs it um i know you sent it out
earlier uh
representative cameron and
representative petrino and
representative grossman
i will send that right out right now um
and then uh you do have representative
yokela and representative kamarota with
hands um
up electronic very good representative
hi uh yes thank you um mr chairman
i definitely think that we need to
propose future legislation
so much so that i've actually already
drafted some
trying to incorporate some of the uh
language that
the was suggested by the unh study
and i've sent that to all of your guys's
email
this morning um right after the
beginning of this meeting
so i think that uh
hopefully that can be a basis for
some discussion either you know in the
in the near future to potentially
move this uh forward as soon as possible
in the next session so thank you
very good representative uh camarota
yes um i just want to share that i've
received many many
uh emails requesting further
uh work on this bill next session
so i um support what
rep desimone had said um and i just want
to see this
go forward for further work thank you
very good thank you
see now i will i'll open up our
executive
um
on house bill 362. anybody want to make
i move recommendation for further future
legislation
i second representative right second by
representative kamarota
any further i'm sorry
seeing none when representative connors
is prepared we'll
take a roll call on uh
go ahead i'm all set uh representative
barian
yeah okay representative mulligan
yes representative connors is a yes
representative diggs representative
french
representative grossman yes
what was that was that a yes yes
thank you representative petrino yes
representative st john yes
representative wazir yes
representative de simone yes
representative rice yes
representative horn representative
camarota
yes representative fowler
yes representative rooney
yes chairman long
yes thank you
very good thank you uh we'll open up in
our committee full committee work
session on house bill 1278
and uh if representative carson could
just give us
a brief overview of his communication
christina did you send that out to
everybody
where she she just emailed the to the
committee
okay i thought i had sent him out also
but briefly i mean this is regarding
the importance of managing psychotropic
medications and foster children
in an appropriate way and the bill
grew directly out of uh
i believe an inspector general report
it found that new hampshire was one of
the states that in particular
had problems with what they defined as
psychotropic medication use in foster
children
part of the statistics were influenced
by the fact that many states use
information gathering systems that don't
separate separate out foster children
from children that are also part of the
criminal justice
system and new hampshire combines them
both
so that is a statistical
influence on the final number but i
don't think that that
is really what's significant what's
significant is
that the intent of
the bill which is to involve the
legislature
in prescribing practices
has a very major flaw
and it's also ill-timed the
dcyf is moving ahead
with a very organized plan
that i outlined in the information that
i set out
that is a plan that involves regional
nurses
throughout the state working with the
relatively small
population of foster children who were
eating psychotropic medicines
and even smaller population of providers
would you ask um mr rep carson
to speak loudly louder his volume seems
to be down for my
um
is that any better match ah life is good
um so uh whatever you did here
of the previous stuff i think it was
sort of an on-ramp more than anything
and the real essentials are that this is
an important issue
it's an issue that exists everywhere in
the country it's an issue that's been
driven primarily by lack of resources
lack of training and lack of supervision
and it is something that the state of
new hampshire is doing a good job right
now addressing
through dcyf's effort to have nurses
in the regions of the state working
directly with the prescribers
and also working directly with
professional
board certified child psychiatrists who
is out of the sununu center
who now has it as part of the contract
for that
for that person to be the direct
supervisor for
the regional nurses that are monitoring
the use of the medication
and to be an available resource for
actual
consultation about medication use with
the prescribers
because one of the problems is there's a
shortage of
child psychiatrists and there's a
any prescriber with significant
prescribing experience
but it's a small population of
prescribers
and they are well connected with the
dcyf system that's being put in place
and i think that what we would better do
as a
committee would be ask dcyf
to give us a report about every six
months or so
about the progress of the nurses in
place
the cases they're reviewing and any
issues that they
are experiencing and what they might
need to correct those issues
because the issues have a lot to do with
inadequate record-keeping
inadequate diagnostic criteria and
inadequate then monitoring of target
symptoms that the psychotropics are
useful for
and those are really critical issues and
if dcyf
can't show progress in two years i think
there may well be
reason for there to be something
different in the way of legislation
there's also the issue that pcyf
leadership changes
and a problem that's high on their list
could fall low on their list
at which point it would be important for
the legislature to make it clear
this needs to remain high on the list
however
that kind of legislation without funding
is useless
so the future may well call for
legislation if dcyf
isn't able to pull things ahead but
that's legislation that should be
adequately funded
and it should not be legislation that
follows the present
bill because it has significant flaws in
how it defines
psychotropic medicines how it defines
diagnostic criteria
and also how it turns to the boards of
medicine and nursing
to give them brand new duties which they
don't have and they shouldn't have
to be telling people how to prescribe
because the legislature is telling
people how to prescribe
the boards of medicine and the boards of
nursing are already available
to consult with any organization that's
putting together
guidelines about guidelines that would
be appropriate
and then it's the board of medicine and
the board of nursing's job
to respond to complaints which can come
from any agency
about whether or not these guidelines
are being followed
but the legislature should not be in the
business
of ordering specific prescribing
practices
or making it an additional duty which
would be unprecedented
for either of those boards to be
involved directly
in the creation of guidelines about a
specific class of medicine
it opens the door to further such
specific classes of medicine
that's not where the profession wants to
go that's not where the legislation
legislature wants to go it doesn't work
things change too fast
so i don't think we should move ahead
with further legislation at this time
and don't recommend that
but i think the child and family law
committee
can work with the dcyf to assess whether
something's emerging that is an issue
that does need
a different legislative approach
thank you representative
representative mulligan did you have
your hand up no thank you
no representative representative petrino
seeing no further discussion i'll uh
open up the executive
uh meeting and
um entertain a motion
representative carson uh
i would move that we do not proceed with
further legislation
i'll second that representative rice
second
seeing no further discussion uh
representative connors
representative mulligan yes
representative connors isn't yes
representative courson
yes representative diggs
representative french representative
grossman
yes representative levesque
yes representative petrino
yes representative st john yes
representative wazir yes
representative simone yes representative
rice
yes representative horn
representative camarota yes
representative fowler representative
jurious
representative yokela yes
representative rooney yes
chairman long yes
okay
okay thank you uh the final bill we have
this morning i'll open up the work group
full committee workgroup on house bill
1595.
and um
the issues i saw in this this this
this bill um this bill requires courts
to oh yeah we can't do this
um sorry uh yeah i recommend that that
it was just it in my opinion it was just
too
open-ended i mean we don't know if the
child already had an evaluation
uh and we'd be requiring them to pay for
another evaluation
i mean i i do believe that it's
the parents responsibility to uh see
fit whether their child needs an
evaluation for
substance use disorder or mental health
um
so i wouldn't i wouldn't recommend it as
further
uh in my opinion rep representative
desimone
thank you chairman long um i agree
i think that um since the courts already
have
for children to receive
mental health uh minor children
uh to to get involved with mental health
and to get involved with um
rehab i think that to
immediately send them to a facility
such as the sununu center could inhibit
their second bite of the apple as it
were
sometimes just referring them for uh
psychological
help and rehab is enough to put them
on the road to recovery and that's
i think where we need to be headed is
recovery
representative rice did you have any
further i did i
i just think that we can't take a
one-size-fits-all approach
i think that you know each individual
case should be
handled on its own merits and not just
lumped in all together
right thank you for those comments
representative de simone any
any further um any further discussion
representative mulligan yes thank you
again chair
um i guess is there anybody here that
sponsored it or are uh sponsored
but i don't have any other i only have
one i'm getting one-sided um
issues is there anybody
that um yeah i'm not going to entertain
any
members of the public i haven't opened
the door for the other two bills i'm not
going to open the door for this bill
so this is just what the committee
senses i mean if
if you're positive on this just let us
know
uh well i just uh you know feel that
uh i would like to hear uh
you know uh both sides of the story
well we heard it already we had a
hearing on this bill representative and
we heard both sides of the story
okay well i would like does there a
in the bill file which is at the state
house right
yeah so i don't have access to it is
that right
and can um does anybody have a
uh a summary of why
the uh co-sponsored the sponsors and the
co-sponsors thought this was a
good bill yeah if i if my memory serves
me correct they felt this was a good
bill
because they felt that the court shall
take action on a child who's had three
or more
is it three or more convictions uh three
or more prior convictions that
they would be required to
um get um
evaluated for mental health or substance
abuse
you know and they felt that that would
that would be a benefit to the state
and for the children so if i'm if
i'm 15 and i'm showing up in court again
for
a drinking violation under age drinking
and this is my fourth time showing up in
court they feel that i should be
evaluated
um i should be evaluated for substance
do you want to respond to representative
mulligan
i'm going to try and turn off
representative barry's video
and see if that helps his audio can you
hear me
you can hear me i don't think can you
you can't hear us all right he can't
hear us
yeah so representative mulligan he can't
you can't hear us no all right can you
it's my recollection yes i can
great no i can hear you
you can't hear us very good go ahead
any further discussion on uh house bill
15.
okay if we can if we can mute
representative variant
poor scam representative long would it
be helpful if i pulled the bill up and
shared it so folks could look at it very
quickly
we want to move on yeah
representative st john yeah i think
we're good
representative st john i i was just
going to add
something to um um what representative
mulligan was saying
and i although i i see the
intent of this bill i think it has to be
done on an individual basis on an
individual case and it shouldn't be a
precedent
across the board every situation is
different
and we would hope that the courts would
evaluate repeat offenders with that in
mind
and not make a a a blanket bill
requiring that so that's just in
response to
what representative mulligan was saying
right
no and i understand i mean because i may
have been evaluated in my fourth case in
court i may have
been evaluated on my second case
however this bill will last that i get
evaluated again
um you know so you're absolutely right
it's on an individual basis
uh representative simone
thank you chairman long again i agree
with what you're saying
um sometimes it takes up to five times
uh for anyone albeit a
child or an adult to go through
rehabilitation and to really
absorb any uh
psychiatric
distance that they're getting so for to
lump it all together and say
you go to court um and it's because of
alcohol abuse or drug abuse that's it
you're going to be incarcerated it
doesn't fit
the needs of everyone it only fits the
needs of
one or two maybe more
but again we can't it's not a one size
fits all as
representative rice said thank you for
any further discussion
okay see and then i'll enter into uh
executive uh
session and uh
i'll move that house bill 1595
um be not recommended for future
legislation
representative desimone ii yes
cnn representative connors would you
take the role
yes representative marion
is that a yes representative varian just
i'll come back to him we'll see if we
can get that after representative
mulligan
uh based on the and i haven't really
been able to hear both sides of the
issue as thoroughly as i would like uh
can i abstain
okay then uh based on that i'm gonna
have to go with no
okay representative connors is a yes
representative diggs representative
french
representative grossman yes
representative levesque yes
representative petrino
yes representative st john
yes representative wazir
yes representative desimone
yes representative rice yes
representative horn
camerota yes representative fowler
representative jurious representative
ocala yes representative rooney
yes pride representative barian again
representative yes and chairman long
yes
okay very good that concludes our
business for today i
i just briefly i want to thank uh
those of you everybody on this committee
uh
for serving their state those are not
coming back i wish you well
um and uh representative rice i
i believe representative barry and
are you okay with writing 362.
okay um
go ahead representative rice can i just
get representative connors can i just
get the
um vote tally for the last one that we
did
yes the first two were 15-0 and the last
one was 14-1
okay thank you any
any further business anybody want to
bring up before we go representative
this
morning
representative i would like to take this
one second or two to congratulate
uh representative rice she has joined
the realm of
oh wait i have pictures being a mimi
congratulations what was that
i love her so much that's awesome
okay thank you christina thank you very
much
and thank the other two uh we certainly
appreciate it and uh
enjoy the rest of your day everybody i
miss you guys hope to see you all soon
take care
bye that's okay
all right bye everybody see your
beautiful bye
christina um who am i emailing the
uh so it if you email them to and
representative long is fine with them
you can either send them to me or
heather
i don't mind either one that's right
okay so
so the the um committee reports we sent
to you christina
uh yes so as long as um they're okay
with you and you want me to pass them
along i can
okay so represent of course and rice
will send them to me and i'll afford all
three of them to you
okay and you'll be um who was the uh it
was
representative two of them correct okay
perfect
that's right and then i'm sorry
representative connors you can
you can send the um the scanned copies
or the copies straight to paul i think
thank you thank you so much have a great